die vierte impfung sie kommt aber nicht
jeder muss sie nehmen und das ist auch
neu die stiko hat gestern einen weiteren
impfstoff empfohlen nämlich nowaks tja
aber was ist denn jetzt anders an diesem
impfstoff wir beantworten gleich die
wichtigsten fragen zu den aktuellsten
empfehlungen bei unserem großen bild
impfgipfel vorher wollen wir aber von
ihnen noch wissen würden sie sich noch
mal pusten lassen
[Musik]
kommt drauf an wenn man uns zwingt oder
ja wirklich erklären sie mal warum weil
es absolut richtig finde jeder der sich
nicht impfen ist verantwortungslos und
egoistisch reagiert ja ich hatte auch
als erstes gleich corona ich war ein
krankenhaus und ich habe es auch zu
hause
heftig auf jeden fall das ist ein
bisschen administrativ und logistisch
nervig aber wenn das der lauf der dinge
ist dann muss man den sie sich dem
glauben führen ich habe das
entsprechende alter und ja ich hier
sogar schon dran wenn es ein vierteljahr
abstand wäre ich habe am vierten
november meine dritte impfung bekommen
und ich würde jederzeit meditierte auch
finde ich nicht gut weil wir
haben keine langzeitstudien da ich habe
mich jetzt auch impfen lassen auch durch
gruppenzwang sozusagen
aber
ich habe meine bedenken also ich da ich
habe fragen so wie ich gerne auch
beantwortet haben möchte aber es wird ja
nicht beantwortet da würde ich habe mich
generell auch impfen lassen weil ich
einfach diese freiheit haben wollte
und wenn es jetzt fünf oder sechs mal
kommt dann ist es so also dann werde es
auch machen ich finde aber dass es auch
irgendwann mal ein ende haben sollte die
die bereitschaft zum erneuten boostern
ist also hoch aber wer muss sich
eigentlich noch mal impfen lassen wie
sieht es aktuell mit dem genesenen
status aus kann er uns schon wieder nach
drei monaten entzogen werden da all
diese fragen die wollen wir jetzt klären
bei unserem großen bild impfgipfel
zugeschaltet sind deco mitglied
professor doktor rüdiger von kries
hausarzt dr thomas aßmann und die
spd-gesundheitsexpertin heike behrens
schön dass sie alle zeit für uns haben
die
erste frage möchten wir direkt mal in
stein professor rüdiger von kries sieht
sind leiter der ag co wird 19 der stiko
und die empfiehlt er jetzt den impfstoff
nowaks wann kommt er denn in deutschland
erstmals zum einsatz und was ist anders
an dem impfstoff also ende februar
sollte er über werden das ist der eine
aspekt der zweite impfstoff ist
grundsätzlich anders ist ein proteine im
stoff ist keiner im stoff und dieser
proteine im stoff ist insofern
anders als hier bei eben keine r anlage
geben wird als hierbei eine
konventionelle im stoff gegeben wird
natürlich manche menschen die angst
haben wohl gemerkt arena impfstoff den
weg zur impfung ermöglicht frau behrens
jetzt soll es den zweite booster
auffrischung geben noch ein pieks und
noch ein pieks und noch ein pieks wer
braucht denn überhaupt diese vierte
impfung
die stiko hat energie klare empfehlung
gegeben alle über allen menschen über 70
würden sie es empfehlen aber eben auch
denjenigen die mit besonderen wollen
nach allen gruppen zusammenarbeiten also
zum beispiel auch den beschäftigten in
den pflegeeinrichtungen
dass man mit der impfung stimuliert man
ja die bildung von antikörpern dadurch
erhöht sich dann die abwehrkräfte wie
oft kann man dann einen körper überhaupt
immer und immer wieder das ganze zu
unten
das ist eine gute frage geht vielleicht
auch eine stiko aber man muss natürlich
sagen nicht nur die antikörper werden
haben gericht sondern auch die t helfer
zellen im körper das heißt also wir
haben mannigfache abwehr gegen den virus
und die impfung soll das stimulieren man
hat sagt nur wenn man zu oft
im stall so setzt 78 19 mal vielleicht
kurz hintereinander darauf nicht betont
kurz hinterher kann es vielleicht auch
zur vermehrten nebenwirkungen kommen man
muss aber auch so sehen wir werden ja
einmal im jahr praktisch kämpft gegen
grippe und das wird sehr gut vertragen
also von daher sehe ich bis ein bis
zweimal ins auf postern im jahr also was
relativ
gut entgegen und ohne größere
nebenwirkungen
professor von krisen wird die frage
gerne auch mal an sie weitergeben wie
oft kann man aus dem körper zumuten
erneute impfung
die frage stellt sich eigentlich weniger
aus dem aspekt des körpers an aus dem
aspekt der erkrankung wenn ihr karten
sehr schwer verlaufen damit kann das
notwendig sein das zu tun im übrigen
werden wir uns je häufiger mit diesem
erreger auseinandersetzen dann wenn
dieser erreger in dem es wird wenn er in
der bevölkerung zirkuliert also ob man
die mit dem erreger über hin vom
auseinandersetzt oder über die
natürliche expedition wir werden es mit
dem erreger auseinandersetzen müssen und
das ist etwas was wir bei anlegern ganz
genau so machen und nur so können wir
eine die mobilität aufbauen die uns
ermöglicht mit diesem erreger zu leben
frau während sich mich noch mal auf
diese empfehlung von der stiko
zurückkommen denn viele menschen machen
sich jetzt sorgen dass das tatsächlich
wieder ein vorbote sein könnte dass der
genesenen status für gepostete schon
wieder einfach so aufgehoben werden
könnte oder zumindest reduziert werden
könnte wieder auf drei monate können sie
den menschen diese angst nehmen wird das
kommen oder nicht nein ich glaube da ist
da kein direkter zusammenhang sondern
beides muss unabhängig voneinander aus
medizinischer sicht sorgfältig bewertet
werden und uns jetzt in der politik ist
es wichtig wirklich auf den rat der
wissenschaft gehören auch den rat der
mediziner zu hören was tatsächlich das
sachgerechte vorgehen ist
hier sehen wir noch einmal die übersicht
wer jetzt gebucht werden soll also über
70 jährige bewohner von altenheimen
menschen mit immunschwäche krankheiten
ab fünf jahren oder auch beschäftigte im
gesundheits- und pflegeeinrichtungen
darüber hinaus glauben sie dass
diejenigen die wir mit den anderen
impfstoffen bislang nicht erreichen
konnten also jetzt mit diesem neuen
impfstoff mit nowaks erreichen können
herr von
kriegswaffen
vorhersehen kann man das nicht aber wir
hoffen dass und das wäre natürlich sehr
wünschenswert wenn das hauptproblem denn
die noch nicht gegeben die noch nicht
einmal geimpft wurden denn das sind die
die davon noch am meisten profitieren
können wenn es menschen gibt die jetzt
noch über 70 sind oder verdächtig sind
die noch nicht geimpft worden dann ist
es absolut sinnvoll dass die von der
neuen impfung profitieren von dem neuen
lift profitieren denn mit ihrer info
kann man mit ziemlicher sicherheit
schwerer verläufe behindert aber
auch wenn man damit nicht die
zirkulation in dem gewünschten maß
einschränken kann der impfstoff ist
nicht perfekt aber er ist geeignet
schwerer verläufe zu verhindern und das
ist ja das worum es eigentlich geht
erstmal nun wird auch viel über
kinderimpfungen gesprochen und werden
auch erst eben stoffe zugelassen für
kinder ab sechs monaten halten sie das
für sinnvoll
also das glaube ich so kleinkinder unter
fünf jahren zu empfinden das glaube ich
muss jeder für sich persönlich
entscheiden weil halt zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt das muss man sagen kleinkinder
kaum ein risiko haben an cupid schwer zu
erkranken aber man kann es halt nicht
ausschließen die impfung halte ich für
sinnvoll für kinder die damals schwer
krank sind asthma haben vielleicht
herzklappenfehler oder so etwas muss
aber kurz nochmals zur wahl was zu sagen
natürlich würde ich mir wünschen dass
auch viele leute die jetzt noch kritisch
sind der impfung gegen nur was neben ich
habe aber selber
ungefragt von den im verweigerer gibt es
kaum welche die auf noahs umschwenken
werden also ich bin da sehr skeptisch ob
das klappen wird leider ja weil die
lebenden vor einer blase ich habe mit
den leuten gesprochen die haben gesagt
ja wir warten auf nummer was ist da da
ist ja das soll noch nicht geprüft und
so weiter und so weiter und so weiter
also ich hoffe zwar dass die leute sich
impfen lassen aber ich bin da leider
leider sehr skeptisch ob die aus ihrer
blase noch rauskommen trotz ihrer
skepsis herr doktor assmann wären sie
denn vorbereitet und auch die anderen
ärzte die impfen oder braucht man da
doch noch die unterstützung von den
impfzentren oder auch von apotheken also
punkt 1 der land hat es immer
vorbereitet punkt zwei unterstützung ist
immer gut also weil wir von einer
zentralen aufgabe stehen weil nach der 5
frankreich vor der sexuelle sein und es
ist besser dass wir jetzt uns
vorbereiten auch mit seinem kollegen
aber auch mit anderen fachgruppen dass
wir bereit sein können wenn noch etwas
kommen sollte schnell zu impfen weil wir
nicht wissen wie weit notiert der virus
nach zum jetzigen zeitpunkt denke ich
dass wir das ganz gut hinkriegen und das
ist auch die impfzentren
wir als land und hausärzte und auch als
kollegen im facharzt bereich des gut
weggekommen wenn die apotheke noch dazu
kommen kriegen wir das bestimmt auch
noch schneller hin ob das notwendig ist
es eine andere sache weil wir leider
sehen dass die impfmüdigkeit doch
abnimmt werden das thema natürlich
weiter verfolgen vielen dank für diesen
impfgipfel professor rüdiger von kries
vielen dank herr dr thomas aßmann und an
heike behrens
herzlichen dank bleiben sie gesund und
negativ sei auch dass
mit dem impfen in zukunft so aussehen
wird das bleibt noch ein bisschen offen
sicher ist allerdings eins hans ulrich
jörges der will ja irgendwie nicht mehr
mit zehn schönen guten morgen und leon
so ist das wieso nicht also ich bin
bisher ein treuer impf bürger gewesen
ich bin dreimal gekämpft ich bin im
november gebucht worden ich gehöre zu
der altersgruppe die jetzt zum zweiten
mal gepostet werden soll der das
jedenfalls angeboten wird das wäre jetzt
im februar soweit könnte jetzt gleich
losmarschieren mich noch mal impfen
lassen und jetzt steige ich aus ich
lasse hole mir die vierte impfung nicht
ab denn es ist schon die fünfte in sicht
das ist ein impfstoff von bei antec
speziell gegen omikron entwickelt das
warte ich mal ab und gucken wir dann an
wie das besprochen wird ob ich dem
vertrauen oder nicht vertrauen
jedenfalls ich gehe jetzt nicht in eine
impf karawane die sich ein bis zweimal
pro jahr impfen lässt ich habe die
befürchtung dass sie mir damit das
immunsystem ruiniere und irgendwo muss
das immunsystem dann auch noch mal
alleine arbeiten können ich habe kein
vertrauen mehr in das was mir jetzt
erzählt wird ich glaube auch dass es
keine schlüssige impfstrategie mehr gibt
in dem moment wo die leute bearbeitet
werden die noch nicht geimpft sind sie
sollen sie jetzt dringend impfen lassen
und zwar dreimal kommt schon die vierte
impfung und sie sehen da kommt noch eine
fünfte hinterher und dann hören sie ein
bis zweimal im jahr das ist da noch die
sechste siebte achte neunte ich glaube
die lassen sich jetzt nicht impfen was
die politik und diese impfexperten im
moment machen es die leute erst recht
abzuschrecken sich impfen zu lassen und
das ist was ich im moment beobachte auch
ein ziemlicher scherbenhaufen der korona
politik generell die im kampagne ist
kollabiert statt 30 millionen impflinge
bis ende januar sind nur 17 millionen
geimpft worden ob es eine impfpflicht
geben wird wissen wir noch nicht da
müsste ja mal die frage geklärt werden
stoll in dem im gesetz auch nowaks
stehen der gesundheitsminister hat
bisher gesagt im gesetz stehen drei
impfungen nowaks wird aber nur zweimal
geimpft also entweder drei mal oder
zweimal nowaks und dann möchte ich auch
gerne mal hören wem wird nowaks
eigentlich empfohlen ist als nur ein
spezieller impfstoff für die impf
zweifler weil das eben ein anderer stoff
ist so klingen oder eine spezielle
wirkung die kommunikation in diesen
fragen ist erbärmlich den leuten wird
nichts richtig erklärt auch die vierte
impfung die sie jetzt kriegen sollen
wird nicht richtig erklärt wir hören
oder lesen aus israel dort ist die ganze
bevölkerung schon damit geimpft worden
und das ergebnis soll sein dass zwar die
abwehr gestärkt worden ist aber nicht so
sehr das ist wirklich gegen omikron
hilft und wenn es nicht gegen omikron
hilft weiß ich nicht warum ich nicht
nach drei monaten schon wieder impfen
lassen soll also die impfpflicht ist
höchst fragwürdig die frage ob die
impfpflicht für für pflegekräfte in
krankenhäusern durchgesetzt werden kann
ist auch fragwürdig weil die
gesundheitsämter die das kontrollieren
sollen sagen dem können wir gar nicht
hinterher gehen haben wir keine zeit für
dann ist die frage was ist mit diesen
impfstoffen sind die zu empfehlen und
dann ist wenn man das noch mal ein
bisschen aus denen den scherbenhaufen
begucken dann haben wir jetzt gerade
gelernt dass die genesenen nur nach drei
monaten
nur noch drei monate tragen nicht mehr
sechs monate dass es irgendwie zwischen
zwei polen da wird darüber diskutiert
ein teil der politik wollte das
zurücknehmen wieder zurückkehren zu
sechs monaten weiß man aber nicht wird
es überhaupt noch ernsthaft geprüft oder
bleibt es jetzt so würde aber auch
bedeuten wenn du sagst ich mach jetzt
schluss mit dem ganzen wust an dass das
konsequenzen hat was restaurantbesuche
freizeitaktivitäten et cetera angeht
kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch das
glaube ich nicht das wäre wenn wenn die
das machen dass sie diese das ist ja
bisher nur als freiwillige zusatz
impfung empfohlen so verstehe ich das
jedenfalls wenn wenn diese vierte zur
vorschrift gemacht wird dann dann fliegt
ihnen das land um die ohren weil dann
folgte leute nicht ist es ja jetzt schon
so wenn ich gewusst hat ist muss er
jetzt auch noch zusätzlichen test machen
lassen was eigentlich ja auch völliger
quatsch ist ich bin seit november
durchgeimpft und in nrw meine eltern die
schon gewusst hat sind müssen wenn sie
ins restaurant gehen keinen zusätzlichen
testen mehrmaligen ich ja aber in nrw
wird auch wüsste ich das jetzt als
geimpfte die im november durch geimpft
ist schon machen viele bürger haben in
deutschland immer wieder gesagt hallo
gerne zu ihrem arzt dann machen wir ein
schon da haben wir nicht was
vorbereiten
hallo
kommen sie zur forschungs info
hello again ich komme hier wegen meine
vierte impfung
ach kommen sie zur fünften
auffrischungsimpfung
halogen ich komme hier wegen meine
sechste impfung
halogen ach kommen sie zur siebten
auffrischungsimpfungen
sabine spitz
gut wir haben da ein kleines bisschen
übertrieben oli aber irgendwie ganz
darauf läuft es auch hinaus andré also
ist es nicht dass das allerdings wird
jetzt genau zu dem zeitpunkt diskutiert
wo den nicht geimpften wirklich dringend
nahegelegt wird sich dreimal impfen zu
lassen und die wissen dann jetzt schon
durch die diskussion damit ist es nicht
getan sind es geht noch viel weiter und
durch diese diskussion werden ja die
impfungen immer weiter entwertet sie
sagen ja zu recht sie müssen in nrw nach
zusätzlich getestet werden dann kann man
auch gleich übergehen zu 1g alle müssen
getestet sein auch die geimpften und
dann ist die impfung nur noch eine art
von selbstschutz damit man nicht wenn
man erwischt wird von dem virus nicht
schwer erkrankt das glaube ich auch dass
das im kern die die wirkung dieser
impfungen ist aber auch nicht immer man
muss schon glück haben wenn das wirkt
und war ständig und wenn man pech hat
ist man auch ausgebucht oder im
krankenhaus ich habe das im
freundeskreis mehrfach erlebt apropos
ungeimpfte die sind ja momentan so ein
bisschen die aussätzigen der nation ja
das halte ich wirklich muss ich sagen
für die vordringliche aufgabe die
zurückzuholen denen das leben wieder zu
öffnen ich halte das persönlich für
verfassungswidrig einen so großen teil
der bevölkerung auszuschließen vom leben
bis auf arbeit öffentliche
verkehrsmittel und einkaufen im
supermarkt das ist kein leben und das
ist eine solche eine solche
misshandlungen dieser bevölkerungsgruppe
es ist ich finde es extrem ungerecht
unmenschlich und außerdem noch
wirkungslos und wir sollten alle mal
drüber nachdenken als geimpfte was wir
den ungeimpften antun wenn wir das
schweigend mitmachen ich schweige nicht
mehr wir müssen dagegen aufstehen und
sagen jetzt holt ihn zurück und das
lässt sich auch machen wir haben jetzt
einen ein virus unterwegs das nicht mehr
so schwere krankheiten auslöst und jetzt
können wir dazu übergehen mit 3g
zumindest also dass auch die getesteten
wieder am normalen leben teilnehmen
halte ich für die vordringliche aufgabe
diese hätten nie für möglich gehalten
dass eine so große gruppe von menschen
in diesem land so konsequent ausgegrenzt
wird und am leben betrogen wird das muss
ein ende haben
sagt hans ulrich jacke ist danke schön
dass du bei uns man braucht